يدك على يدك بعد
تلك الطقوس القديمة التي تعود
إلى ما قبل فجر التاريخ الشموع
والصلاة في كهف في
منطقة أفرين شمال سوريا ، أعضاء من
الأقلية اليزيدية التي ينظر إليها متعصبو داعش
وغيرهم من المتشددين الإسلاميين على أنهم
[ __ ]  وصل الكفار إلى
ضريح عسل جيل على التلال القديمة
للصلاة من أجل الخلاص ، تمثل شرائط القماش
المربوطة بالأشجار
صلواتهم الفردية.هجوم تركيا في عفرين
يبلغ الآن شهرًا تقريبًا وتقول أنقرة إنها
تلاحق وحدات حماية الشعب الكردية وحدات الدفاع عن الشعب الكردي
التي تركيا  يتهم
حزب العمال الكردستاني بأنه فرع من أعدائه اللدود ، حزب العمال الكردستاني ،
الذي يقاتل الدولة التركية
منذ عام 1984 ، بسبب
الهجوم التركي الذي أعاد إحياء
ذكريات مجزرة واستعباد جديدة ،
ولا نريد تكرار ما حدث في
سنجار هنا  يقول هولاند حسين من
المجلس الإيزيدي لأفرين في إشارة
إلى قتل واستعباد
آزيتا العراقية من قبل داعش في المجموع.  عام 2014 ، جاء
جميع سكان
القرية للصلاة إلى الله أن يحميهم
من ويلات الهواء ديوان
ومرتزقته والمتطرفين الإسلاميين
حتى وقت قريب وقد نجت أفرين من
وطأة الحرب في سوريا ،
وهناك الكثير منهم.  أصبح مشهدًا
مذهلاً للصراعات التي تمتص
الأمريكيين الروس الأتراك الإسرائيليين
حزب الله اللبناني ومجموعة من اللاعبين الصغار ،
الشيء الوحيد الثابت هو
المعاناة التي لا نهاية لها على ما يبدو للسوريين العاديين
[موسيقى]
فقدت فاطمة ابنها واثنين من
أحفادها في غارة جوية تركية على
المسؤولين الأتراك في وطنهم  الإصرار على
أنهم يحاولون تجنب
وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين ، تشير هذه اللقطات الحصرية
التي حصلت عليها سي إن إن إلى أنه قد لا
تكون الشظية قد دخلت دماغه ، ويقول
هذا الطبيب إنه يحتاج إلى عناية مركزة ، إن
جروحه خطيرة.
الأقلية العلوية الكردية في
حين أن الأكراد العرقيين
يتبعون نفس الديانة التي يتبعها الرئيس السوري
بشار أ  لأنهم يخشون من غضب
القوات التركية وحلفائها من المتمردين السوريين
الذين يعتقد الكثير منهم أنهم
جهاديون ولا يوجد ما يمنعهم
من دخول هذه المنطقة وحرقها
وقتل أهلها واستعباد
نسائها كما فعلوا في سنجار.
عذابنا ورئيس المجلس العلوي الكردي في موتلي ،
لا يوجد الكثير مما يمكنهم
فعله سوى إشعال شمعة والصلاة في
الظلام المتجمع